hey how's it going Brad
look there's conquer that's Leonardo da
Vinci in the background I didn't realize
that anyway welcome to conquers bad [ __ ]
name a lot of brothers have been
suggesting the game to me and not be
wanted to play it for a long time so I
read a little all about it and it got
amazing reviews I mean of course it's an
old game but I didn't know it was like a
classic or whatever so that being said
let's go Nintendo presents oh I didn't
know a Nintendo made like offensive this
game is really offensive by the way no
no no it's not offensive it's this kind
of like no what do you expect and
hearing this music it's definitely flung
from Clockwork Orange clogging orange is
seriously my probably my favorite movie
out of all time starring conquer and
berry I just love that movie I watched
it probably like 20 times and I never
get tired of it yeah it is it's dragon
drinking the Malacca plush the Malacca
Plus milk gobbles
it's [ __ ] awesome I would give this
game 10 out of 10 already just cuz it
has a Clockwork Orange reference [ __ ] is
he doing
come on bad will there be women on the
sides well they're big plates like that
are big naked women
maybe you just zip um that milk I don't
really look like it I don't even know
what's going on what's going out what is
that guy that's not a naked woman
what's that [ __ ] well well I am there
you are
conquer the king all right that's all
the land like that Sweden - no no way
you think
you probably kill a lot of people yeah
who the [ __ ] are they
I did say that accident it's a long
story
tell us all about him okay tell me
started yesterday a black heart there it
is Conker's Bad Fur Day the title and
everything oh man I'm looking for it and
I hope you're looking fine you're
looking skeptical over there what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
just kidding you look beautiful over
there that's what I meant to say keep it
up Wow your hair is like so luscious to
me all right not is that pixelated I am
listening to Nicki Minaj answer it woman
Jay's like a barrister
and some chit women hello Jason sky fat
she's doing karate moves
I'm gonna be a bit late to some I know
fight some fight some more awkward it's
the [ __ ] oh no I paused outside
it's a [ __ ] front answer of why
machine they know they know a shed again
what conquer are we on this say I win
the same thing you five a fiver someone
loved your fiber
how you doing that okay that's not good
you guys enjoy yourself and all that
probably see as I'm dying we never drink
too much concave jad the bad isn't even
playing are they the [ __ ] and the plaka
that's a good good and
if I ever create a bar it's gotta be the
[ __ ] at the plaka card this bro bar bro
bar sounds bad actually
is he gonna see is that guy holding the
Testaments
the Old Testament what the [ __ ]
how about a old chat ago what is that
guy holding what the fog so confused
go that way yeah that's er but it came
from the other way he's gonna get lost
brows
nasty or nice can't quite make it out
it says nasty and nice familiar me don't
go to nasty woman I mean it was a bunch
of bees but don't worry about it
there's none of those ways what the [ __ ]
it goes in between metal on that nice
annoying I'll shed is the evil violent
breast he lives up in the castle I
always wanted to be an evil bear living
in the castle oh is where we are gonna
be fresh it's donkey mango milk what the
[ __ ] how would a cat ever say no to more
milk it's actually a panther I think or
is it I don't know it's gonna fall
Oh Kitty's not happy about that how
about suffer that [ __ ] table
Oh Jeff he's gonna get past Pussycats
gonna get PF sorry I just wanted to
replica that yell or whenever it was
how are you can't care are you bit
although re okay I can relate conquer I
can totally relate you have to pay for
what you did the day before this is how
it is conquer all right well the the
thing and majiggy gosh it I post it as
you may or may not noticed I'm emulating
this game I just find it to be a lot
easier to if you're recording to emulate
them [ __ ]
how are you can't get are you alright a
bit of a headache
your tongue is sticking out I don't know
if you notice that that I can do like
his tongue I don't know I know about
your buzz I have a really long tongue
don't screen cap that don't do it
alright what's going on
oh yeah I'm concur mouth hello hi can
you help me I need to get home and go to
bed cuz I don't feel very well
Clark on care man he just want to go
home oh no no no no you gotta help me at
all Sonny you can never trust the
Scarecrow this baby yeah yeah all right
okay
what's your name ready Freddy
[Laughter]
but first good oh okay I get it
okay buddy hey can you help me yeah but
hey what the [ __ ] I'm standing on end
what be pressing me I love technology
[Laughter]
what you're doing more is that a
Budweiser dumb I don't mind if I do
[Laughter]
of course you don't mind if you do yeah
what the hell it means
what no I don't get it
I don't get it do you get it no you
don't even get it right again well I did
enjoy the ting sound but I think I'll go
over there - that's one thing I was this
one day Malaka plus oh you took an
aspirin all right is that what it's
called in English just what I needed I
think so yeah it would think to me that
these give me talks even
yeah I don't see it though yeah yeah you
wanna oh okay
why would I skip the wonderful cutscene
much but you will have to live watch
them at least one nah [ __ ] I thought it
was weird because I was trying alright
we're faster than [ __ ] now yeah kaga you
look badass man
girl you oh nevermind jumping on the
head
hello how he has those [ __ ] pads or
whatever oh man I actually I'll tell you
in a second
uh-huh more yeah
and I should crap
okay hey
I could do that I could touch my guts do
dogs then a gay do that funny helicopter
tail
helicopter tail thing
but a lot of this game it's like no yeah
I got it J smullin I helicopter thing
oh he's tales from Sonic what the [ __ ] I
when I was really young and I couldn't
swim you know when you had those pads on
your arms I was like [ __ ] this I don't
need this so I jumped it I jumped into
the pool without them one day I was like
I don't need them I can swim even though
I couldn't and yeah man nearly drown and
then we would what if that happened we
didn't even have like pizza what the
[ __ ] is this
I have been terrible I think there were
too many watching this video that I have
to drink again
oh you're a real charmer please know
what a [ __ ]
come on Adam you just don't come free
have you ever sat on a piece of gothic
rock its shell then it's right to think
it's my spider come on please a little
bit early in the day to start talking
about gothics is correct no no I'm
coming close i [ __ ] what you gonna do
about my shampoo
alright what happens if I pull this
allow why are [ __ ] happy look
sometimes he goes from yeah huh what
what in the hell what in the heavens
what an RF conquer your mom okay let's
go back to our that door thingamajigger
was Oh calm down [ __ ] Riku
can I call a Concord Co I think I will
call your [ __ ] gurkha
all right what's going on in here wait
look at that look at that look at that
look at it look at AB now I'm a look at
hang on what something didn't I Heather
you had a bye
try pressing B all right I'll do they
are you gasps woman Jace might be whoa
now I see where left her dad got the
reference I like their ideas from [ __ ]
come here come and fight fight
come on come here please please please
okay I don't have all day all right
let's corner him let's corner Han oh
yeah Oh son you just got bitch-slapped
how does that even wash it it is for
whatever I okay stop thinking piss wait
that's the breathing for me okay tail
jump dinner
Derr Derr Derr Derr
wait that's another Charlotte
transformers du/dr door I guess we can
[ __ ] slap this [ __ ] now but stop
respect yeah what you going to do her
body
[ __ ] yeah what's up what you gonna do
now [ __ ] good job conquer
why are those flowers invisible
the flowers died oh my god no I'm so
sorry no conquer don't you dare fall
down don't you dare I taught you better
than there o kidding up here
transformers do dodo dodo that's up
thing that song it's totally on my brain
right
alright I think I know it's gonna happen
now
yeah fantastic
oh let's go and get some shut-eye let's
go and get some shut-eye
all righty then let's go one kiss I save
your life flowers where the [ __ ] is my
thank you oh that's right keep dancing
see if I care
Jace shipping fake oh it's a kitty cat
ik what what Huff's okay this Jeremy I
forget what is this what did that
[Music]
Oh professor well
I have a job for you
okay thank you can see the table it
needs another leg the time-bar look good
not good okay I think I said okay what
happened last time
oh the duct tape what the hell happened
with the duct tape
[Laughter]
grab anti-gravity chocolate that was
there that's what the [ __ ] winner
[Music]
notify what is your reading beaver porn
dude can't care what the [ __ ] are you
doing oh no make that make that shine
that conquer get the [ __ ] up again
that's what they're oh look at this play
it's beautiful
all right cool we're back here at the
naughty and nice saying you really
[ __ ] up yesterday conquer I conquer
you want to do a nacho like fairy radar
O'Connor that's actually me I'm trying
to be funny anyway I pressed Susan your
last time be sure to label a comparator
they really have me out a lot
subscribe to grammar today and I'll see
you next episode
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
I love how